des sénateurs du rassemblement national
vous dites quoi enfin
oui enfin tout ça et je veux dire assez
normal puisque ça correspond
aux évolutions politiques que nous
constatons quelque temps et le fait que
le rassemblement national revienne
arrive on peut le dire comme on veut au
Sénat était pour nous en tous les cas
attendus ce qui les témoin c'est les
scores avec lesquels nous arrivons nos
candidats partout sur le territoire on
multiplié par trois quatre voire 5 les
résultats de la précédente du président
renouvellement sénatorial dans les mêmes
départements donc ça veut dire que nous
avons sur un corps électoral qui n'a pas
beaucoup bougé parce qu'il y a pas eu
beaucoup de changements aux municipales
et bien nous avons convaincu des
électeurs de voter pour nos candidats et
en cela c'est une deuxième victoire la
première c'est de faire entrer trois
sénateurs Seine-et-Marne Nord et Pas de
Calais trois jeunes élus trois élus de
terrain et la seconde c'est les scores
que nous faisons qui je crois bouscule
beaucoup évidemment ce qui était attendu
est-ce que une surprise parce que vous
aviez moins de conseillers municipaux
après les dernières municipales par
rapport à celle de 2014 qu'elle en est
l'explication pour vous est-ce que ça
veut dire qu'il y a aussi eu des grands
électeurs indécis que vous avez donc
convaincu oui évidemment je pense que
nous progressons et nous réussissons à
convaincre de la pertinence de nos
analyses et de nos solutions les
Français et leur représentants c'est à
dire les grands électeurs qui votaient
c'est une évidence et ça se passe
partout en France partout sur le
territoire puisque du Lot-et-Garonne où
nous passons je crois de 22 voix la
dernière fois à 100 voix aujourd'hui
jusque évidemment au nord nous avions
238 voies nous en avons 433 sur un
collectoral identique et bien oui nous
considérons que nous avons réussi à
convaincre des grands électeurs et ça
aura forcément des conséquences
[Musique]